Speaker 1: We've spoken before on the program
about Lara Logan. Lara Logan is a. She at least
was a journalist, and she did some really
good work when she was with 60 Minutes.
Something happened to Lara Logan and I know that
many say David. What happened is she was brutally
assaulted when doing coverage in the Middle
East. And she has PTSD. That's what happened.
Maybe it is. I don't know. Something happened
to Lara Logan, where she is now on Fox Nation,
repeating some of the most rancid conspiracy
theories that we have seen in the political
media space for the last 10 years. And
most recently, Lara Logan suggested
that Darwinian evolution may be a hoax
funded by Jews. Now she, for a while now,
has been using some of these anti-Semitic tropes
and talking points of globalist you. Almost when
you hear the word globalist, you almost have to
say globalist like Alex Jones globalist stuff,
Rothschilds all these different things. She
appeared on. Honestly, I don't even know what
this is. It's a show called And We Know. And
she suggested that Darwinian evolution may be a
Jewish funded hoax. Listen to this.
Speaker 4: So now you've gone from being a farmer
who may not be able to farm efficiently, who may
not be able to feed as many people. But guess what
he could feed? He could grow food year after year
after year, because who created seeds that are
renewable, like truly like created life that is
truly renewable? What is the only thing on Earth
that is actually renewable? Hmm. It's life. And
they can, you know, go back to The Big Bang Theory
and Darwin. I mean, when I found out, does anyone
know when who employed Darwin when communism comes
from? No. Go ahead. Well, I mean, you know, look
it up, the Rothschilds. Yeah, it goes right back
to 10 Downing Street all the way the same people
who employed Darwin. And that's when Darwin
wrote his theory of evolution and so on and so on.
Speaker 1: Guys did. Did you know that? You know
what she's suggesting here is? The theory of
Darwinian evolution didn't come from Darwin
doing real science Jews, the Rothschilds hired
Darwin, and then all of a sudden he writes this
theory of evolution and then knew what.
Speaker 4: I'm not saying that none of
that is true. I'm just saying Darwin was
hired by someone to come up with the theory
correct based on evidence. OK, fine.
But, you know, even the people fine.
Speaker 1: I guess it was based on evidence.
Speaker 4: Well, the scientists, all of the
people that can take you back to the Big Bang,
what is the one question they can never, ever,
ever answer? They can never tell you. Whatever
that was with, it's the molecules or the energy
or all that stuff. All these scientists like
that. You know, that evil, horrible person was
the science adviser to Klaus Schwab at the World
Economic Forum, who says there's no such thing
as freedom. There's no such, you know, there's
randomness, but that's not freedom of blah blah
blah probability. And there's this and there's
that you can explain it in a way any way you like.
But how did those things come into being? Yeah.
You know, and it was it was a combination of
if that question of what came first,
the chicken or the egg. Right?
You can't answer that scientifically.
Speaker 1: Now, as many of you already know,
this is and often this is a sort of god of
the gaps, a hypothesis or talking point,
which is any phenomena that cannot yet be answered
by science. Or maybe never will, but it doesn't
make a difference. You put God into those gaps,
so we don't know now what was there before.
Everything. I mean, it's a very complicated
question. It's a scientific question. It's
a philosophical question. It's a
big question. That doesn't mean,
you know, it's Jesus or Zeus or whatever. There's
no evidence for that when it comes to Lara Logan,
first of all. This is this is disgusting, right? I
mean, Jews funded the hoax of Darwinian evolution,
even if it was maybe based on some fact. That's
her idea. Do you think that she started believing
this stuff? So then Fox hired her? Or is it that
Fox hired her and it got her to start spouting
this stuff? It's hard to say which way it goes,
and there may be some, some way in which it's
both. But this is a real life cautionary tale
about a lot of different things about how right
wing media will write your brain and listen if
PTSD is part of what's going on with Lara Logan.
It's a cautionary tale about that as well,
and it's not for any of us to diagnose what's
going on, but I feel it relevant to mention
that she did suffer an insane situation, and
not long after that, these have started
to be her ideas. So make of it what
you will. No comment from Fox about these
completely outrageous comments by Lara Logan.